hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview but before
we get into this interview i want to
talk about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primex bt is that
you can also follow some of the best
traders in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex bt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got daniel
here with me thank you so much for doing
this sir
thank you so much for having me on it's
a huge huge honor for sure let's just
jump right into your background you've
uh worked at a lot of really crazy
places uh and done some amazing work so
what'd you do kind of
uh over the last few years yeah so my
background's
definitely bizarre when i try to explain
to people and just to try to rewind it i
basically made the decision
uh when i was really young when i was uh
getting ready to go to a four-year
university that to drop out of school
and pursue a career as a full-time
designer that took me to
apple took me to square where i was
there for five and a half years and
scaled the design team and worked really
closely with
jack dorsey and keith boy and a lot of
the incredible team members at square
and then for the last two years just to
skip and skip forward a little bit
i've been taking on a very different
challenge which is i felt like i had
um i got a lot of experience
kind of seeing what a venture back
startup was like working at square and
investing in other early stage startups
and i wanted to see
the complete other end of the spectrum
which was what does it look like to go
into a private bootstrap business
that is in trouble and needs to be
turned around and that's the challenge
i've been working on for the last two
years and
that is with andrew wilkinson chris
sparling at tiny and the company i've
been working on there is flow
what is flow yeah so flow is uh
historia i mean i'll jump back to the
beginning when it first launched it was
basically task
management for friends so the idea was
we all have stuff that we need to do
some of that stuff overlaps with our
friends
uh you know this pre-covered world when
you would say do something like put
together a party
you might wanna tell your friends to
bring different things and bring it to
the party
um that's how it started so it started
off on the individual side
it's moved pretty heavily and the focus
um that we had
um when it came to flow was largely
around teams so we
i do we have everything from kind of
task management project management
calendars we've also recently added
stuff like chat and direct messaging
into the app
and the goal there is just to create the
world's best productivity platform
that's well designed that's something
you actually want to
work in uh and use every single day and
so we've got
some amazing companies that are on the
platform our sweet spot today is for
teams that are probably somewhere
between 50 and 300
in size got it so uh
you had this epic run as an operator and
designer
and now you are running this turnaround
with uh with andrew
and tiny and just been on multiple times
and is fantastic as i always say
um what's maybe like the biggest
surprise so far
um kind of going into this turnaround
situation
that you didn't know at the beginning
but now you're like wow i wish i would
have known that when i first started
yeah i mean the thing i definitely
wasn't prepared for is the emotional
challenge of turning around a business
and what i mean by that is you know
um that i think the best analogy that
anyone
anyone can kind of understand even if
you're not an entrepreneur is
imagine accepting a job and every single
month you're getting paid less and less
and less you look
at the direct deposit that goes into
your checking account and every month
it's maybe ticking down say 500
and at first it doesn't feel too bad and
then really quickly all at once you're
just like oh my god what is going on
what's going on and you're seeing your
that kind of revenue dip down
that is one of the things that is really
really really challenging where i think
um you know my kind of take on it was
what interested me
about the opportunity was to learn what
it's like
so i've been invested at this point in a
hundred plus early-stage companies as
well as cryptocurrency and i'm sure we
might talk about some of that stuff i
also do
have portfolios that i manage in the
public markets um and so i've
really been fascinated by investing that
obviously means i'm interested in
business
and the challenge that i wanted to take
on was what does it actually look like
to be in the ceo chair to turn around a
company and
uh yeah i mean i could talk about that
for a lot longer but the short answer is
it's brutal and it's really difficult
just on the kind of emotional management
side that is uh
that is how leadership goes right it is
uh brutal
it sounds like a very good description
uh
word to use um i want to talk a little
bit about kind of some current events so
maybe let's start with public markets uh
we have seen all kinds of chaos
transpire
i know you're an investor in public.com
a couple other companies but just like
zoom out a little bit and help me
understand kind of your views on
what's going on in the public markets uh
the whole wall street bets in reddit
and uh and kind of anything in that
whole arena
yeah just so maybe to zoom out a little
bit i mean
just to start off with i guess my own
portfolio um so i manage
um there's two strategies that i have in
the public markets that uh
fit the way that i think about the world
um really neatly and that i really enjoy
and it's i have one called future shape
which is largely making kind of arc
style bets
arc for anyone that uh doesn't know you
know i'm talking about arc invest which
has the etf ark
and largely invest in kind of next
generation disruptive technologies
and the idea there is just i think
generationally we are in
a time where we're seeing companies that
are going to be
the biggest players in the next 10 years
begin to go public
they're obviously going public at very
high valuations but we are seeing i
think a step
function change in the in the markets
and part of my kind of thesis which i
know a lot of other people
um are of a similar mind is so i first
started out focusing much more on the
venture capital side and part of one of
the aha moments
for me was okay well if i do this in a
pretty industry agnostic way
and if i try to do this in part for
research for what's coming next to the
public markets
i have a really interesting look into
what's going on what the competitive
landscape looks like
that's true even for take something like
coinbase or like crypto
like if you're an investor in coinbase
uh you're gonna have a much better
much more clearly articulated point of
view about what that looks like as a
public business if you invested in a
private and there's nothing shocking
about that
so i i do that piece and then the other
portfolio that i managed is totally
different and it's called the perpetuity
fund
and what i invest in there is almost the
polar opposite into the spectrum which
is closely family held
businesses that that have been in
business for an incredibly long time so
an example of that would be something
like
lvmh which owns louis vuitton it's a
huge brand
it's run by one man who's uh on a tear
he owns a significant portion of the
business
it's not going anywhere owning a luxury
business is
an incredible thing um so i'll stop
there and uh
kind of transition and one thing that
has been just fascinating for me is
those portfolios collectively are up 30
in january which is outrageous
no most people would you know close out
a year
at 30 percent and be like oh my god i
had the best year of my life and here we
are at the end of january and up 30
so clearly things aren't making sense
and clearly the valuations you know and
i
said to a friend the other day i'm like
i really believe in the businesses i'm
invested in
but i know that they there's no reason
they should be trading at the valuations
that they're at
and here's where it gets really
interesting is you know i i read a book
recently
um by george soros which if anyone's
interested he has a super thin book
that's all about his concept of
reflexivity which i think we're seeing
play out a ton today which is just
the idea that um you know if you take
the
uh efficient market thesis and the idea
that all businesses are
always valued at exactly where they
should be valued because the market's
this magical
thing that finds this this perfect
equilibrium
that's not true because humans at the
end of the day are investing and there's
a
shitload of different style investors as
we're seeing today there's wall street
boys there's
uh you know endowments there's pension
funds there's uh
you know kind of people managing for
retirement so there's a bunch of
different actors kind of in the
in the markets doing different things
and reflexivity is just the idea that
if the price goes up on an asset that
starts to become self-fulfilling at a
certain point and people then believe
that it's worth this amount which then
feeds you know we're seeing that
i would say in crypto we're seeing that
in things like gamestop we're seeing
that and a ton
even just you know seeing airbnb and
doordash and how they're valued now
post-ipo
uh they've we have effectively jumped
five years into the future in their
business and that's what
what the stock's trading at today um so
it's just it's it's an incredible time
when you think about that is that
healthy like do you think it's like hey
it's going to correct in the future do
you think it's just
no we live in a different world now and
yeah sure there are
overvalued businesses but that's almost
like the new normal and it will persist
i don't think it's unhealthy at all and
i you know they're
i really disagree you know i i follow a
lot of really smart investors on twitter
and generally i think they fall into two
buckets of this kind of
question and one is the market's going
to do what it's going to do and if
something's overvalued today
that doesn't mean that it's going to
correct in six months doesn't mean it's
going to correct in two years you know
and you have no idea when that
correction is going to happen i think as
an investor you always want to be aware
of how how closely you feel like the
price is tethered to the reality of that
business
but i think what we're seeing is also
again part of my thesis behind that kind
of future shape fund and investing in
this next
generation of disruptive technology is
these are companies that our generation
sees as their companies and they want to
own them in their portfolio they want to
own them in size
and you know if they look at square or
they look at doordash or they look at
um you know airbnb i don't think they're
going to quibble with the valuation i
think they're like this is a great
business i believe in it it's not going
anywhere
so i think it's just um in my mind i
think net net
it's always better to try to
just be a student of the times and if
things are you know so as an example
i'll give you a practical example
so i said my portfolio was up 30 in
january um
i think for a lot of investors they
would say well let's just go ahead and
start closing out those positions or
let's go all the way into cash and i
know a lot of people that are all in
cash
but in my mind i feel like why would you
do that why wouldn't you set stop orders
yet you know 10 underneath the current
price let it continue to ride up maybe
take money off the table as it goes up
but you know if you're a proficient
trader you can effectively limit your
downside risk and continue to enjoy the
upside gains and i just feel like today
for anyone who's in a fully cash
position i'm just like
you're you're certainly missing a really
incredible window of time
and if you're in a cash position now you
could be in that cash position two years
from now because i think you know yes
we're
at historic highs but that's not to say
it's not going to go higher
i think that's the one thing uh that
people always
forget is like almost like the relative
aspect of it so yes we are we are
uh high relative to the past
low relative to the future and that is a
good or bad thing but just
you got to remember this as one point in
time and you only have really half of
the equation
uh and you frankly have the wrong half
of the equation like if you want to know
uh performance you'd like to know what
the future performance is not the past
performance right
yes and the best book on this which i
listened to recently i've read recently
that is incredible although you've
really got to like
just go go with it because it's not
always easy it's misbehavior of markets
which talks all about fra
it talks about fractals it talks about
um it's it's basically
a very very in-depth study
by looking at markets and trying to one
it totally debunks the
idea of the efficient market hypothesis
two it talks about that by and large
markets have almost never been efficient
and markets always go lower than they
should and much higher than they should
and so what that's helped me to do is
kind of reset the way that i look at the
world and just
understanding that there's a much wider
spectrum of outcomes and things that
could play out
than i think most people like to
entertain and i just feel like
net anyone that's always looking
backwards to try to define what's going
to happen in the future it's never ever
ever gonna happen so i think you want to
like stay in the game
just make you know and that's part of
why yes are we at
elevated prices yes uh do i think it can
continue to go up yes could it could we
see a large drop
yes okay you take all those things that
can either lead you to do something like
go in all cash or it can lead you to say
let me just put some downside risk
mitigation by putting some stop-loss
orders in
and let me you know continue to write it
up and be in a position to benefit
absolutely when you think about uh kind
of the whole idea of wall street bets
and
reddit and the little guy versus the
hedge funds like any thoughts there and
just in terms of
uh maybe even robinhood and public.com
like how do you think about all of that
uh market dynamic or market structure
stuff
yeah i think it's i mean to me it's like
a hilarious dark comedy what we're
seeing play out because
you know you take like i've had a bone
to pick with robin hood
since since robin hood came out and my
you know
on the on the pro side let me just start
there i think it's wonderful
that robin hood has served as an on-ramp
for a lot of people in our generation to
become investors and start investing i
think
every person has a right to have money
in the market and be able to invest in
the things they care about
and robin hood has made it really easy
now let me flip to the to the to the
negative side
the negative side is i think
unfortunately
this whole idea that you should sign up
for robin hood i think
the reason you're signing for robin hood
is it's a well-designed app the reasons
not to sign up for robin hood is because
it's free
it's commission free trading because if
you do any bit of research and this is
now
you know been made public although a lot
of people i think still aren't aware of
it
if you do any research yes you're
effectively not paying commissions but
you are paying commissions because
you're always paying a price that is
higher than the best price you could get
on the market because as you see they're
selling their order book to citadel
and these other hedge funds they're
effectively front running it adding in
um a bit there and it's just a whole
notion and i think it's
you know anytime you see one you see a
value proposition like that it
always helps to dig in and think about
why does that value proposition exist
and how are they actually achieving that
value proposition and running a business
and in this example yes it's commission
free
uh but there's a whole bunch of
downsides and
um those downsides are you're not
getting the best
rate you know stuff like we're seeing
today where robin hood has effectively
made it so you can't search you can't
invest you can't even see your positions
if you've
if you've already invested in gamestop
or knock or
some of the other kind of short squeezes
that we're seeing play out
and um so i've always had this bone to
pick with robin hood and just to talk
about
just to talk about that like the other
thing i find really fascinating is
um you know the only way they could
achieve this commission-free model was
by effectively kind of screwing users
just doing it in the background without
them really knowing about it
um and uh you know if you think about
um just where we're at so think about
not robin hood but all the other
brokerage options you have today
what's kind of hilarious to me and part
of the dark comedy piece is
sure it's nice to not pay commissions
but we're also at a point in time where
you're paying the lowest commissions in
the history of investing if you invest
on any platform
and those commissions are in the low
single dollar range
and you know by going and using an
actual brokerage
fund you know i use interactive brokers
um there's a whole bunch of stuff
i don't love about it it's an atrocious
ui i waited 30 days to get my
application approved like there's
just maddening stuff with it but at the
end of the day once you have an account
set up
they're not going to restrict what you
can trade you can trade anything that
you can trade
and you're going to you can uh set up
trades in a lot of sophisticated ways
and get the best and get the best prices
and just one other thing that i would
say is you know i invested in public.com
maybe two years ago and i'm huge fans of
what they're doing and really the only
reason i invested and this is part of
the reason i want to talk about this a
little bit is um
that i felt like they were running the
ethical values based model that robin
hood was doing which is
we we the same mission we think that
everybody has a right to be able to be
an investor in the public market and
they should be able to do that by an app
that's on their phone
in an amazing experience but then from
there they're doing things that actually
help
uh work in people's best interest you
know so uh they're not selling their
order book to people like
like citadel they're actively warning
you when stocks or options have very
high volatility
and those are the things where i think
robin hood has taken a very hands-off
approach which is which is fine
but i think part of opening up the
floodgates and making it so everyone can
invest
is knowing that clearly not everyone's
going to be competent and know what
they're doing
and it doesn't mean that you need to
limit them but you need to help educate
and inform them and i think publix
done an amazing job there so i would
highly recommend
anyone who's on robinhood that's
interested in switching you should
absolutely go check out public if you
want to have a similar
style app you're lucky that you got
equity that's pretty damn good pitch
i uh while we're recording this uh my
phone keeps blowing up and people keep
sending
uh all sorts of things where there are
many of silicon valley
kind of heavyweights who normally would
not say anything negative who would kind
of
you know let the dust settle uh
literally
i won't say who it is uh but uh there's
a very very well known person who
literally just tweeted just
f robin hood right i mean just like you
know the sentiment just
switched and i think that yeah they're
destroying their brand today for sure
it is not good but uh but hey you know i
i do keep saying to myself look there
may be certain things that
we aren't privy to right if if the
regulators come to your office and say
hey if you don't do x
you're going to be in trouble like you
know i know i think it's just
people don't like disingenuous behavior
and when you when you
make the robin hood promise and then you
do this later on you need to know that
that's a risk
and you're going to upset a lot of
people completely agree
um so if we kind of switch gears to
crypto i think there's a lot of people
who think bitcoin and crypto and
decentralized finance and all this stuff
is the solution what are your thoughts
there
yeah so crypto is uh it's i don't even
know where to start but i guess just to
maybe set up my history on it so
um i was super fortunate in that um i've
got two younger brothers
uh both of them are amazing um but one
of them got a job for coin
working at coinbase as one of their lead
engineers maybe about four or five years
ago
and i like the way that i view the world
is i think generalists rule the world i
think everyone
you know should be a specialist in some
areas but i think generally
uh with just the way the world is
changing i think
being a generalist allows you to connect
dots and see opportunities that
you're not going to see if you're just
you stay in your niche and we're at a
point in time where
because we're all connected because
there's so much disruption because
there's so many different
kind of companies getting spun up and
opportunities that are all around the
world
i think being able to look super broadly
and connect those dots puts you in a
better position and so i've always just
been fascinated so i just started asking
him tons of questions about crypto
and he helped you know i ended up
reading the bitcoin white paper and
um and where i netted out and this is
generally
uh how kind of my investing style when
it comes to disruptive technology is
i do not need to in fact i actively try
not to
come to a definitive this is good this
is bad point of view i think the best
way to think about the world
especially with disruptive technologies
just probabilistically so in my mind
i read that i was i was confused uh in a
lot of different levels about how
bitcoin would
how bitcoin worked you know how it
actually um
operated how the blockchain actually
worked how transactions happened
and i think that's one thing just that i
learned early on is that the crypto
spaces
i think there's a ton of really
compelling opportunities it is also
one of the least accessible most
intimidating
marketplaces and industries in the world
right now and you know i know
things are improving there but um crypto
has a long ways to go in terms of making
it so the average
person can actually understand and
engage um
but when you think about that is that
like a user experience standpoint
is that something that can get um solved
through education like you
you know you kind of uh sit this very
interesting position where uh you were
the head of design i think right you ran
the design team
at square square's obviously made this
massive push into the space done a great
job
uh been very principled and kind of
really put a flag in the ground
uh at the same time you understand
design you understand making a beautiful
experience which square and cache habits
enough have
so how do you think about like is is
that the solution is it more of just
the user experience or something else i
mean
yes i think there's more education that
can happen i think
uh you know seeing um firms like like
square with the cash shop making the
bitcoin buying and holding in custody
experience great
is amazing because it uh you know in my
mind it just eliminates all the
complexity of if you try to have your
own wallet you try to custody your own
keys you try i mean it just becomes very
complicated very quickly
if you try to kind of spin it up on your
own so i think that's all wonderful but
i think one of the biggest things is
crypto is still an industry where nerds
are building for nerds and nerds need to
build
for everybody and what i mean by that is
like um
you know i one of the investments i made
in this space is trust token which
became trufy and um you know it's been
really interesting to watch how they
play how that's played out and i think
that
raphael there has done a really great
job uh recently with the launch of trufy
and how that works
it is you know so i'm a large investor
there i
those tokens are beginning to come
liquid it is still super super super
confusing you know i can stake that on
loans
um and i can look at these loans and try
to say whether i think they're going to
pay it back or not pay it back
but you get very bad information about
what you know why is someone borrowing
this what's your payback rate
so there's like these technologies where
you can use crypto to
um you know be able to kind of vote on a
loan and earn a
return for that loan but none of the
other things make
sense you know i'm not giving any
information about who's borrowing i'm
not giving great information about
their payback history i'm not giving
great information about the mechanics of
it and so i think just
in my mind net net crypto just needs to
uh
you know if honestly i think the beacon
is applicable you need to take
complicated technology
and you need to put it in a wrapper that
makes it drop dead simple for anybody to
understand
and i think that's where crypto keeps
shooting itself in the foot
yeah so i i wonder if um
is the promise of decentralization the
promise of the lack of market
manipulation
you know all the kind of things that i
think people today especially when
they're watching the game stop
and and uh day trading and um you know
kind of wall street vets all that well
they're watching that play out is the
decentralization promise enough just to
start pulling people in that direction
and then as more people come we get the
improvement of uh
the design or do you think that it's
kind of uh no the design's got to
improve so that when people
do look for decentralization they can
actually be onboarded and it works
yeah it's a great it's a great question
um
i mean i am of the standpoint that
almost no one understands what
decentralization is
and it's still a buzzword and the if you
were to ask the average person even
someone investing in crypto to
articulate that really clearly that most
people wouldn't be able to get past
maybe a sentence or two honestly
explaining what that is and um i think
that um
yeah in my mind i think it's right now
we have i would say
but if you look at cash app you look at
coinbase i think there
are great experiences for people to
invest
in you know the kind of blue chip assets
in the cryptocurrency space so things
like bitcoin things like ethereum
once you get beyond that and you get
into the world of tokens
i think it is incredibly convoluted and
incredibly confusing and so in my mind i
think it's just
you know part of what i think is
fascinating about the crypto space and
why i
even though i admitted that i didn't
fully understand it and i admitted that
there was a huge range of outcomes some
of which were crypto would be a very big
thing and some of which crypto would
not i still thought it made sense to
place a bunch of bets
in this space and that's because it is
incredibly disruptive technology that i
think will define
a lot of what things look like kind of
five and ten years from now but part of
what that means is you're working on the
cutting edge
you have to have a team have a mentality
have an approach
where you're building those things for
the average person and you know i would
say too just maybe to make the devil's
advocate point of view
most people investing in tokens they're
not the average person you know and i
still think
that is not where the average consumer
average investor is going to invest
but those tokens were created with the
intention that the average person would
be able to use it so someone that wants
to store files could choose filecoin
instead of dropbox and in terms of
making that a reality
for the average person who couldn't care
less about bitcoin or ethereum
but is really compelled by some by some
utility like file coin
making it easy for them to choose and
use filecoin over dropbox is we still
have a long ways to go you know to do
something like that
got it and and when you think through um
the crypto businesses is there anything
that changes the evaluation when it's
like hey the stock market's like pretty
us-based-centric pretty western world
uh you need to have a bank account you
need to kind of all these things then we
go to this crypto world
uh with bitcoin as kind of the core unit
of account and all these decentralized
applications and now that's like a
global thing
do you see that the global aspect having
a material impact
or is it more just now we're gonna take
the western model and just more people
it doesn't necessarily change anything
specific about
about what's going on well i mean i
think that is still
uh in my mind one of the key things
underpinning why something like crypto
is the future of you know kind of store
of value or is the
the future of currency is just the fact
that
uh for the first time in human history
we have one
we have kind of something that is global
in nature and decentralized in nature
that anyone can transact on and i think
that in my mind is
um some of the most compelling most
interesting use cases
uh of bitcoin you know that we're seeing
is seeing how people use it in emerging
countries seeing how people use it in
countries where the currency's been
devalued
and that's where i can really um in
those cases
i totally buy the argument that bitcoin
is superior
to you know kind of the currency in that
market and i think that bitcoins is huge
blessing that people
have this kind of global uh this yeah
this global currency
that they can use to be able to transact
get paid in store value in
um but i think what gets just in my mind
there's a bunch of other things that are
just
difficult about it or still i find kind
of full mixing and one of those things
is
um just the notion that
you should invest in bitcoin because
it's a store of value but it's a store
of value that's also going up like a
speculative asset that if it's a store
of value at some point it will be a
stable asset in which it's not giving
you crazy returns
and it seems to me like all of the
investors investing today
on it as a speculative asset are the
people who would not
own a put a dollar in it when it's a
stable asset and it's a stable store of
value
um so i think there's still some things
there that in my mind you know
we are i i do think we're certain i mean
you know you look at the stock market
you look at almost any market now we're
certainly in some sort of a speculative
moment in time i'm not going to call it
a bubble but
um and we're seeing that play out but i
will tell
where does this all go do we just
disrupt the entire
system and we end up in a decentralized
digital world
uh all the assets are digital every
application's
decentralized and it's just literally
the system has a reset or
kind of how do you see um maybe maybe
not the
end but kind of the you know the next
big milestone
um kind of environment yeah i see it
i i am not of the mind that this is
going to displace
the traditional company or the
traditional currency or the traditional
centralized way of operating because
honestly if you look at and study
um you know like why companies operate
in a centralized way most of the time it
becomes really obvious that typically
that actually is the superior way to
operate you know and so i think that
in my mind uh what crypto is
um is kind of a a beautiful new model
that i think will stand alongside
the ways that we've always thought about
currency and companies and and
kind of entities and stores value and
all of those things
uh and i don't think it's yeah so i
don't think it's going to displace that
at all
but in my mind that that means that it's
kind of
it's almost like booting up another
planet with a different series of you
know kind of environmental conditions
with it
that support different ways of doing
things and different ways of thinking
about things and i think that's what's
super interesting and fascinating about
the crypto spaces
that because it's different it one it
doesn't need to displace anything that
exists today
it can be a new thing that is a new
environment these things can operate in
it can operate via different conditions
you know you can get to really different
outcomes because of that
um so i think it's just a really
compelling
very different way of thinking about the
world and we'll see how it we'll see how
it out plays out
but i think that the underlying
technology behind it is fascinating and
i think
that if you're an investor and you're
someone who wants to make bets on the
future of technology
i think there's a lot of really
interesting things happen in the crypto
space
yeah what uh what other areas are you
interested in
i i mean yeah my my main areas are
really
uh i love studying businesses so all the
time
um you know like i was just reading a
paper the other day it was a
kind of a case study about louis vuitton
and how they think about booting up
their businesses and that's because i'm
super interested in lvmh and
i'm kind of luxury brands like that
because i think they're incredible
businesses with
huge moats to be able to get into so i
love studying studying businesses
i love uh you know studying investors in
the different ways that people approach
investing that's how i've gotten to
you know kind of my model and i think
really the thing
i don't know if one thing i would share
there that has just really hit home for
me over the last two years and has made
a
huge difference in the way that i invest
is just getting really comfortable i
think the best investors if you look at
is if you study investors i think the
best investors one
know how their brain works know how
they're wired and what i mean by that is
what companies what businesses
inherently make sense to you you know is
it a
blue chip type business is it a value
type business is it a
disruptive growth business and really
understanding kind of your nature and
what i mean there and this may be a good
example
is um you know for people that are
investing in in uh
in crypto like if you're investing today
and your experience and say you invested
three months ago your experience has
been
amazing your experience has been riding
up this almost unstoppable
train of returns it's very different
from someone who invested four or five
years ago you know where
i remember starting to invest and it was
2 500 and for a very long time
being you know significantly underwater
and uh
you know holding on to that in order to
kind of get the returns that we're at
today and so part of my nature is
i know that i can experience a ton of
pain on an investment if i really
believe in it
that's why i also believe that everybody
has to start with how does your brain
work how do you view the world
what kind of and then understanding what
investments snap into place with that
and i think if you do that you know then
um
you can uh bet on things with a
tremendous amount of conviction because
you can never borrow conviction from
anybody else it's just not a thing
so you need to do your own homework
invest in things that make sense to you
and um and come up with your own formula
and that's why when i see people on
twitter debating whether value or growth
is the right approach
it is an idiotic conversation you you
make you can make great money being a
value investor you can make great money
being a growth investor
there's uh success stories to show for
both there's failure stories to show for
both
and so in my mind it just all goes back
to all of us are wired very differently
our brains
are wired very differently we're
interested in different things we
are triggered by different things so why
don't we start there
stop kind of demonizing different ways
of viewing the world and just
understand that there's a tremendous
amount of ways to win you just need to
figure out what your way is
yeah i think that's a fantastic thing um
and way to think
if you had to go and you had to look at
early stage investing what's the one
thing that you look for in an early
stage company opportunity or team like
is it the market
is it the product is it the founder is
it something else
just how do you think through that and
kind of what's the one thing
it's all i mean in my mind it's
absolutely all team and really there
it's almost all soft skills and what i
mean soft skills or or intangibles and
what i mean by that is i think
you know so my experience taking over a
declining business and turning that
around over the last two years
has just hit home that uh succeeding in
business
it it you have to be in it to win it
this cannot be something that you're
trying this cannot be something that
you're giving a shot
this has to be something that you're
like i am building this whatever it
takes i will figure this out and i will
build this because
what you find out really quickly and you
know i think we're in
the uh i think it's fair to say the most
competitive time in human history
in terms of if you look at almost any
industry there are now more competitors
vying for market share with you
there are you know more disruptive new
entrants i think it's harder
to if you have had success in the past
to sustain that success and
change with the times and hold on to
your users and your customers
and so if all that's true i think what
that means is
that it takes a lot of very
intangible things to be able to succeed
and so what i look for is
i want to know that this person like has
honestly put themselves in a situation
where their backs up against the wall
and
ideally they've done that by their own
accord and they're like this is what i'm
doing
i don't care what it takes i'm doing
this for the next two two years
five years ten years and i'm going to be
successful at this and make this
successful
because i think as well too what you one
thing that i've been fascinated by and i
think like one of the
uh insights i've had of investing in you
know hundred plus early stage companies
is
it is uh the winners that you have are
typically
you wouldn't have picked those or you
would say i think this is going to be my
100 x return investment when i made that
investment you're often very surprised
by who wins and who fails and who blows
up along the way um i think you also
realize that
uh you know take a company like uber
being getting to the point where you're
actually
a trading sustainable business and we
could debate whether that's uber yet or
whether they still have time to go
but that's now taken what five ten
different chapters in uber's history of
trying different strategies having
different leaders having different
teammates on focusing on different
markets
adapting to different competitors and so
you just really realize that
building a company is a multi-stage
thing and what does that mean that means
that
there you're going to have success with
something and that's going to stop
working and you're going to have to go
and figure out what that next approach
is what that next
turn of the wheel is in order to get
things moving
so again just all of those things i
think um
boil down to the fact that you need to
have somebody that's in it 110
you need to have somebody who's very
gritty who's very determined who's very
disciplined
um and i think that more than anything
honestly determines whether you're going
to survive because founding any company
building any company it is like being
thrown in the deep end and you're either
going to sink or you're going to swim
and so you want to find the people that
whatever it takes they're going to swim
and they're going to think it's a
successful thing
so i usually wrap up with three
questions uh i actually asked a couple
of different questions for sure for this
um because you've just got such a unique
view of the world that i really uh enjoy
it
um if you had to pick one market uh for
the next 10 years you put all of your
money in that market it's not a company
but an actual market what's the market
sure
that's a great question i mean first
thing that comes to mind although i
can't i i
i'm sure i would change my mind and give
it enough time is investing in
and kind of uh innovative disruptive
fintech brands some examples of those
that i find really
fascinating in the public markets today
is uh a company like
live oak oak bank which i won't i'll
just stop there people that are
interested can go and look it up i think
they're doing really interesting stuff
i think another example there is upstart
holdings which um
does kind of um payday advanced loans
and loans but they do it in i think a
really interesting way
and the thought there is i think one i'm
sure for a lot of people they're like oh
that's an easy answer there's so many
fintech companies there's so much money
happening there
and again it goes back to i think just
you can either look at that and say oh
all those opportunities are done
that you know that means that it's
overcrowded it's over hyped
and there's going to be consolidation
there's going to be stagnation there i
actually
look at it very differently which is
money is one of the largest markets on
earth
that you can that you can be in we're at
a period of time where
um you know josh wolfe of lux capital i
think has a really has this really great
idea
that really what you witness in any
generation if you look at public
companies
is almost no public company survives
long enough to be in business 50 years
later and have their same position in
the market
so what you're always seeing is this
perpetual trending out of
what's worked in the past with the
newest models that are coming in and are
displacing that and so i think
fentec is a massive market there's a ton
of disruption
that means that destruction is going to
be value destructive there's going to be
a lot of things that go to zero or go
out of business
but that also means that i think the
players that are the big players are
going to be very different 10 years 20
years
than they are today interesting could
not agree more
um the second question that i always ask
people is about their sleep schedule
um and uh this is brought by uh the guys
over at uh eight sleep
um i sleep in the bed every night this
thermo deregu or thermocount
deregulation we need deregulation but
thermal regulation
uh of just having a uh a colder
environment to sleep deeper what's your
sleep schedule do you sleep
you know five or six hours are you a
nine or ten hour person
what what uh yeah so my question my
answer is
uh people aren't gonna love it probably
eight sleep's not gonna love it but so
i've got a
a four week old baby at home and uh
we've this is our second kid and so what
that means is i'm in the period now
where literally i'm probably sleeping 10
you know 30 minutes at a time 10 times
in a row over the course of a night
that's being broken up all over the
place
so my sleep schedule right now is
atrocious that being said
i do focus a lot on having kind of
making sure that
i get great sleep and what i do there is
i put on literally
about from the time i get home i'll put
on red light blocking glasses and use
those the entire
night uh to have on even if i'm not
looking at a screen
i'll use something like the juve which
is an amazing kind of near-infrared red
light instrument that if i'm ever
feeling just super amped up like i had a
big day or i've just
dealt with a lot of stress or anxiety
using that before i go to sleep oh man i
can feel just that heavy feeling in my
body after turning on that light and
using it for 10-15 minutes
um you know and then i use uh like a
manta sleep mask and a few other things
but
um my answer right now is my sleep
schedule's not great but i aspire to get
back at some point
to having unbroken eight hours the one
thing that i always tell people is the
one excuse that you're allowed to have
is i have a kid because then it's not an
excuse you're just you're just trying to
survive
exactly well and you're trying to make
sure that your kids survive
so that you can survive right so amateur
and that your spouse
you know has help it's it has help and
support and so you know i we
we sleep my wife and i sleep in the bed
with our uh are in the same room with
our kid every single night that means
that we're both up all night long but i
think that's the best way to do it
i love it uh before i let you go i got
one more question you get asked me one
uh aliens are you a believer or
non-believer
i i mean i in my heart of hearts i'm a
believer i think there's the skeptic
side the kind of rational side that
wants to overwrite that
but um i mean i saw that there was a
news story recently of i think it was
like the former
head of uh mossad or something like that
for israel said that there's a galactic
federation they're just waiting for us
to be ready
i i hope that's true i hope that's true
that's the world i want to live in
um um i'm with you i don't know about
the galactic federation but uh
but i'm there what else what's the one
question you got to uh to ask me
i i mean so uh and it's probably a
little bit of a
just kind of i don't know write up of
your it's like a
a base hit for you but um i'd be really
curious you know i know you're obviously
an incredible proponent of bitcoin and
cryptocurrency and i know you've you
made a huge bet on that
um and um you know you made a good a
great call there
how so i guess my question is let's say
we jump forward
and i'm just going to make up a scenario
that is our wildest dream say bitcoin is
at 50
000 or 150 000 per individual bitcoin
it ha it is this established store value
we you look at public companies and you
see something like
10 20 of those public companies have
some portion of their treasury in
in bitcoin it hasn't been annihilated by
the central banks
so at that point it's less speculative
and it's more of a universal ubiquitous
store of value
what what i don't know what would your
thoughts be what would your message be
how would you think about holding it and
investing it at that point in time
yeah i mean i just i i i just um
you know value or denominate my wealth
in bitcoin and so it's just i just think
of it in bitcoin and it's just because
over
you know the rest of my life let's say
i'm very fortunate i live 60 more years
right
it is going to continue to preserve my
purchasing power better than any other
asset that possibly could uh could
happen so i think that that's just
generally
um the way that i think about it and so
it's less about like
oh it went up a lot in u.s dollar price
i gotta sell it like sure you can
measure
uh appreciation in dollars but
i never will plan to go back into a
dollar denominated world right it's just
like no i am going to
uh continue to hold this because it will
preserve my purchasing power and i think
what becomes even more interesting is
like
okay then what happens when you
denominate the rest of your portfolio so
rather than holding stocks
you hold these digital or tokenized
stocks right what happens when this gets
tokenized from this and this
and eventually you just have 100 digital
portfolio and so i think that like we're
moving towards that world
um again i think people are just
drastically underestimating like the
sentiment shift that has happened in the
last huge
four or five days uh and so we're gonna
see what happens here but i i just think
like that world is gonna become much
more attractive to people than uh the
legacy kind of rigged the game world
last question do you think that aliens
will be interested in bitcoin
what is it didn't somebody ask i think
somebody asked elon what is uh
you know what's like the currency on
mars and he said i think he might have
said crypt i don't think he said bitcoin
but like whatever he said you know
uh i don't think we're gonna bring gold
i don't think we're gonna bring dollars
so i guess the only thing
left is uh there we go there we go
that's it uh awesome man listen where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or uh or find more
um of the work that you're doing yeah
people can follow me
on uh on twitter at uh dana scrivener
they can also go to danielsgrivener.com
and my last name is s-c-r-i-v-n-e-r
it's a horse german name so a lot of
people misspell it um
and uh for anyone that's interested um i
have a podcast where i
profile uh investors and entrepreneurs
that are building the future called
outliers people can
uh follow that at my website
danielscrivener.com and for anyone
that's interested in flow
um we would love to have you give it a
try uh at
getflow.com amazing man listen thank you
so much for doing this i really really
appreciate it i think people are really
going to enjoy this one
um so we'll do it again in the future
thank you for what you do thanks for
having me on
awesome